welcome to architecting startups with
google cloud where we showcase our
startup customers and how they are
architecting and deploying their
production ready applications with gcp
i'm felipe modella and i lead one of the
customer engineering teams that is
focused on startups
today i'm happy to welcome edwin
margulis he's the ceo of 3o which is an
ai
powered
contact center as a service platform
that is
using a lot of our gcp solutions
very happy to chat with you today edwin
and welcome
thanks felipo
for the kind introduction hi everyone
i'm very happy to chat with you about
trio today
perfect so
edwin before we start just to set some
context here just today just this
morning i spent a lot of time
trying to you know contact this company
and just to solve some issues like as a
consumer was like one hour and a half
going from their chat bot to the phone
call and then transfer between agents
and me having to give all the background
so it was a little bit frustrating so i
just want to share that because that
kind of helps us on our conversation so
tell us a little bit about 3o and how
theo is trying to solve these type of
issues today for customers
sure well just like customer service
problems you were talking about earlier
companies have challenges because they
unknowingly create friction for their
customers
3o has a mission to remove as much
friction as possible from customer
service transactions
today customers are tired of bots that
don't help and hold times that are too
long and having to repeat themselves
over and over
so we use google gcp to solve these
problems with a careful balance of human
assistance coupled with automation
this careful balance
it's made possible with the liberal use
of google ai
we help brands to focus on smooth
customer journeys we do this by giving
customers choices
maintaining context
and using automation when it's needed
these choices include the ability for
customers to communicate the way they
want to communicate for example they can
choose
sms chat
social media bots email and of course
voice
all of this is done with a seamless
transition between different
communication channels
oh well so thank you for the
introduction i
i'm just curious
does the platform also handle like kind
of pre-sales like sales leads intake or
is more focused on customer service type
of channels
oh that's a great question filippo
uh well yeah absolutely we handle
service and also sales in fact uh with
3o brand managers can orchestrate just
about anything from lead capture to
sales qualification
scheduling product reg
sentiment feedback just countless
workflows and all of these omnichannel
transactions are hosted in google gcp in
fact
we use gcp and google ai and our own
microservices as part of a digital turn
style
gracefully pivoting from one form of
communication to another and we also
maintain context from channel to channel
so customers don't have to repeat
themselves
okay so digital turn style that's
interesting i like the analogy
and like i mentioned i know you're using
a lot of our solutions
so can we go a little bit deeper now on
how you're using gcp overall
sure well the idea behind this digital
turnstile is primarily about let's call
it orchestration
you see we're kind of at the center of a
vast set of processes data sets ai
resources customer touch points
so the 3o application orchestrates all
that data and communications flowing in
and out
so at the very heart of this so-called
digital turnstile is our built-in
workflow engine
it touches every single transaction so
we can add all kinds of value on a
transaction by transaction basis
in fact it's the workflow engine that
decides if the transaction requires
special treatment such as
google language translation or google
data loss protection
so google gcp allows us to deliver all
of this on a global scale with uh high
reliability and security built right in
well perfect thank you so can we go down
a little bit deeper actually
break down a little bit of your
architecture can you probably cover a
little bit how are the main comp what
are the main components within your
architecture today
okay sure well there are different
aspects of 3o's architecture that all
lead to this uptime and scalability we
talked about
there are three
core
google gcp clusters in what we call the
internal part of 3os architecture there
are also three google support clusters
we'll address a little bit later okay so
you mentioned three uh within part of
the core
clusters
sure now they're the provider cluster
the 3o application cluster
and the telephony cluster
so first the provider cluster is used to
orchestrate microservices and to do
software updates kubernetes is at the
heart of that orchestration the provider
cluster also handles authentications and
load balancing
now the second is that 3o application
cluster it houses microservices that are
application specific
for example multiple instances of chat
servers workflow service email
scheduling services to name a few
all of these services communicate over a
common ip messaging bus and all are
orchestrated using kubernetes
and the third is the telephony cluster
and it houses microservices but these
are specialized for functions like phone
calls conferencing recording and webrtc
connections to contact center agents
that are using google chrome
okay so
you also mentioned as part of the kind
of the core services you touched on the
ai portion
i'm not seeing necessarily this within
these specific clusters so do you have
other like supporting clusters outside
which ai would be part of it
oh yes
in addition to those three core google
gcp clusters we've talked about there's
also what i call the google support
clusters that are part of the
architecture and we use these to connect
services cloud to cloud they include the
google operations cluster the google
analytics cluster and the google ai
cluster
so the google operations cluster houses
all kinds of essential services such as
google cloud monitoring and google
google cloud logging
the google analytics cluster is where
google bigquery and google cloud storage
live
the google ai cluster is where we access
all the google ai goodies like google
cloud natural language dialog flow cloud
speech detects data loss prevention and
google cloud language translation
okay and how do they how these
supporting customers now communicate
back or connect to your main core
cluster
right so
basically we do that with workflows that
are that are
managed by our robotic process
automation and workflow engine
and these uh are in the application
cluster that we mentioned before for
example when a call ends we can
automatically send follow-up sms's to a
customer or do fulfillment or callback
scheduling this automation allows agents
to do wrap-up tests very quickly before
going on to the next transaction
interesting so
i think part of the core
cluster that you mentioned
you
touched on the name microservices as you
were talking about the digital turn
style analogy
and
mention of course gke kubernetes
and i would like to understand how how
was the adoption for your team of
kubernetes and
the microservices type of architecture
in general how's your experience so far
well let me tell you that
kubernetes was a welcome addition to the
mix
of our architecture
the need for containerization and
orchestration was a very big part of our
architectural decision and design
so gke makes the replication of services
and distribution of new software very
straightforward
in the past
the 3o team members did this with
proprietary software that took many
years for us to develop
with google gcp and kubernetes however
we're able to manage many different
clusters all around the world with great
ease
the amount of labor required to manage
the network is easily less than half of
what it was with previous architectures
that we designed
now with google gcp it is also easy to
scale
up or down
you know depending on seasonal traffic
loads and high peak demands and adding
capacity is now more automated uh
depending on the anticipated load in a
region
oh i you know as a customer engineer
myself as a solutions architect i'd love
to hear
time savings scalability and of course
uh the more reliability and ease of use
so
let's talk a little bit now about i
think in our on our previous
conversations uh
we we you actually mentioned one
interesting thing that currently your
platform has no
window for
maintenance right so you always 24 7
your application is alive
so can you tell us a little bit more
about that how do you eliminated that
maintenance window
uh using gcp
yes um well we'd love using google gcp
and especially kubernetes because it
helps us deliver service with zero
maintenance windows
it's no small feat
i mean 3o's founding team are
world-class architects who have built
modern ccas platforms over the past
several decades
and we ourselves had to build a lot of
tools and earlier platforms for
inter-process communication
orchestration and redundancy
in fact our larger service provider
customers really care about this
especially for their clients who run
three shifts
of course this is enabled in large part
because of kubernetes
the clear benefit of zero maintenance
windows is good old-fashioned business
continuity right
no business wants to be shut down or
held hostage by software that requires
downtime
yeah i
i actually
think would be useful uh
to actually go a little bit deeper on
that workflow that we were mentioning on
your application
and how these parts connect together
usually when i'm talking to a customer
to understand their architecture what i
actually what i actually asked the
customer is their customer journey so
maybe that's a good way
for us to provide this a prompt so if
you were to describe
an usual customer journey
uh in could you walk us through a
customer journey where some of these uh
multiple channels and how can i that
turn style
happens behind the scenes
sure here's an example of a customer
journey that illustrates how 3o
leverages google gcp and google ai
first customer connects to a google
dialog flow bot and will later escalate
from that bot to a live agent and live
agent chat that is and finally to a live
phone call that gets recorded and
transcribed
so let's uh let's see how that works
so first
a customer goes to a website and they
click on a bot avatar to start a
self-service interaction here of course
we use google dialog flow
second a secure connection is
established between the website where
the bot surfaces and the 3o environment
here the google load balancer and
provider services connect to the
appropriate resources inside of our 3o
application cluster
and then third the through application
cluster services look up associated
journey information for the target
landing page on the website and it loads
other information from the google
bigquery database and then engages with
google cloud automl text to analyze
customer intent okay ellen so
what if now
the customer does not want to talk to
to the automated to the to the bot so
they want to just transfer and chat with
a live agent
on that specific chat via text how does
your platform handles that
sure well you know based on that
scenario a customer can escalate to a
human-based chat when they're done with
google dialogflow
um essentially all the customer needs to
do is type the word agent or give me a
live person or something related to that
or click on the live agent avatar then
we automatically engage the 3o chat
server in the 3o application cluster
next we do a database lookup in google
bigquery and also check the intelligent
router for available agents to connect
to that is the ones who are properly
skilled to help that particular customer
and we use google cloud automl text to
help with the classification so we can
then do the automated routing uh in a
very quick and professional way
finally the 3o chat server in the 3o
application cluster sets up a channel
with a live agent
after notifying the agent of the chat
request and then information from the
google dialogflow bot session is sent to
the agent screen so the agent can
continue the dialogue with the customer
while seeing the context of the previous
session with the bot therefore
eliminating the need for the customer to
have to repeat themselves
okay okay last part now that i'm curious
now you're talking to this human agent
on the chat
and then for some reason
you need to go from the chat now to a
phone call
is that possible and if so how is that
handled in the back end okay well that
would make for like the second
cross-channel escalation in this
customer journey right the first one
being the escalation from the dialogflow
bot to a live agent chat and the second
being a switch from chat to phone well
we can handle all of that not a problem
in this case the agent views the
customer contact record and sees the
customer's phone number retrieved from
google bigquery now the agent can
terminate the chat and simply click on
the phone number with her mouse to call
the customer
in reaction to that click made by the
agent the media controllers in the
application cluster send call setup
information to the telephony cluster
which in turn establish a phone call leg
with the customer via regular telephone
network
and then the agent is patched into the
call via webrtc
that is a webrtc connector in google
chrome
okay and i'm assuming when you having
these conversations
i know that they're most likely being
transcripted to be either saved on your
system or like as part of your analytics
uh workflows so is that something that
your platform does today and and are you
using any of our solutions to do that oh
sure well
an agent or a google dialogflow ivr can
ask permission to record a call for
quality purposes
and with that permission recordings are
enabled
so in this case an agent activates
recording with a button in the 30 ui
using chrome
and this sends a signal to the google
application cluster
which in turn tells the telephony
cluster to begin recording
afterwards the recording is stored in
google cloud storage
also the 3o workflow engine in the
application cluster causes the recording
to be streamed
to the google ai cluster so we can call
upon google cloud speech to text
the resulting transcription of the call
is also sent to google cloud storage
and do you do like any type of analysis
on these calls for example like if
there's any concerns within the text
like you want to evaluate the quality or
you want to escalate to like a
supervisor based on what was said on the
call
do you do any sort of analysis on what
was said oh sure in fact based on the
parameters of a customer journey the
google cloud speech text is used to take
the transcribed text and stream it to
google automl natural language
for analysis of compliance phrases
the results are then returned to the 3o
application cluster
and supervisors can get involved because
the user service in the application
cluster sends live agent dashboard alarm
to the supervisor indicating that the
agent missed a compliance phrase while
talking with the customer
the supervisor then reviews the
transcript and sees the misses
now the supervisor can start a
one-on-one chat with the agent to coach
the agent on the compliance phrases that
were missed
and this is set up using our chat
service in the application cluster and
company directory
look this is just one of hundreds of
flexible customer journeys that can be
achieved using 3-0 okay well thank you
i'm curious now on the data piece
like i mentioned this is something that
i'm imagining you are processing
hundreds of thousands if not millions
you mentioned like you have a global
uh global scale uh global reach
so what do you do with all the
information not just the calls but the
metadata from these calls
what do you do today with that
sure well
we use google bigquery to house all
transaction histories
it's used for analytics dashboards
special integrations with other systems
that bigquery has helped tremendously
with 3o partners such as larger service
providers and bpos who need direct
access to their own data
in these larger service provider
scenarios a 3-0 partner may have their
own instance of google bigquery running
the partner will give 3o permissions
via google security token service
to read and write to the database that
is their database
customers are able to run their own
queries that are unique to their
business and in addition they can run
the canned reports that that 3o has
written as well
well i i it's very unique use case like
where you're allowing your customers
almost like using this titanic scenario
with bigquery allowing them to create
their own data did you have any
challenges implementing uh the solution
like something that you could share
sure well you know at first the extent
to which customers would be running
their own queries would affect other
customers because the spirit of ccas is
that it's a shared tenancy arrangement
where you achieve economy of scale with
shared use
so in the beginning that shared use did
provide some challenges
so we overcame this lopsided nature of
some of the larger customer resource
allocations by segmenting the
architecture with separate hosted
instances of google bigquery for larger
service providers
okay and
if you were to do any future
enhancements to your architecture would
you like
do you have any any any plans or like
something that you could share with
those watching a little bit what's
something that you it's on your roadmap
yeah i would say that you know we'll
continue to expand our suite of ai based
services based on google ai
um
you know at present we offer google data
loss protection
dialogue flow ai based classification
uh google sentiment analysis google
speech to text
text-to-speech
google natural language you know so our
focus in 2022 will be more enhancements
to google agent assist technology
to augment our own robotic process
automation
okay certainly
a lot of our menu there included and
just to
wrap it up how can
uh people watching learn can learn more
about 3o okay sure uh well the best
place to go is 3o.com that's t-h-r-i-o
and there's a lot of information in
there about how we use google and all
the applications that we provide
you just saw how theory is able to host
global applications with ease using gke
restore and analyze millions of records
using google bigquery and also provide
an intelligent contact center as a
service all powered by google ai
to serve their global customers and bpo
needs around the world
if you found this video helpful and you
want to watch more architecting with
google cloud videos please make sure
that you like this video and subscribe
to our youtube channel
you